so guys a video has resurfaced of Andrew
actually playing with his own daughter
in his home in Romania
this music
[Music]
I didn't know we had a dog daughter yeah
they both got multiple kids I knew
Tristan did it because he because you're
about it I just never I think Andrew has
a few I mean it's it's he was pretty
secreted about it for a while but then
obviously stuff just comes out one of
the dudes on um valuetainment kind of
blew up his spot just pretty dumb of him
it was really cringy but um they both
got some some minions running around
who you talking to
[Music]
music it's like
this is like Children's Hospital
commercial music the hell
it's sad man
it's pretty sad that he has um they both
got little kids out there listen man
this this is the plight of a lot of
people around the earth you just had
little kids and then the Matrix attacks
you and you're locked away that would
suck man it's shitty there are a lot of
people in jail right now some who fully
deserve to be there some who are over
sentenced yeah and some who are waiting
trial and some who are innocent or all
have kids at home that they can't be
with that they can't raise and those
kids have to deal with their fathers and
their mothers being in jail it's really
screwed up and sad and I am and I do
feel sorry for Andrew and Tristan's kids
that they're dealing with this but
they're also dealing with it in you know
the highest style and with I'm sure
tremendous love and care and at least
not wanting for food and basically no
yeah obviously so these kids are
protected fed loved you know it's a
really sad situation though you know
Tristan missed his daughter's birth or
his kid's birth well because he's he's
locked up right now isn't that crazy
yeah that sucks
[__] [__]
[Music]
[__] it's funny how like this
footage comes out now I mean Tate's team
is very smart so they're probably
intentional about filming like very
wholesome footage like this ahead of
time in case something like this happens
to him but it also could just be someone
who was just recording him it could just
be the baby's mother yeah could it yeah
totally it could just be stuff from her
phone it's definitely smart to push that
push out that video now though to put a
better light of Tate out there not like
this means anything in the eyes of the
people that don't like him because
they're so brainwashed that not nothing
would change their mind I mean there's
still no evidence and people hate them
so it's ridiculous um I I put something
up on Twitter today about I responded to
um we have a black congresswoman here
named Diana Presley and she put up
something you know about Black History
Month and about reproductive Freedom
meaning abortion rights and I've put up
a comment about oh so you mean it's okay
to kill a hundred thousand black babies
every year like and tell me that black
lives matter can't help myself and
and some you know one of her one of her
you know disciples basically said
hundred thousand where'd you even get
that number from and so I was like I
went to the CDC and I pulled up the
statistics and I said I'm sorry I stamp
corrected it's actually 130 000 30 black
babies a year I thought it was more yeah
no that's just black children I still
thought it was more it's 20 million
black children have been aborted since
Roe v Wade took effect 50 years ago so
uh the same people that tell me that
black lives matter want black women to
exterminate their children that's 20
million lives that could be uh surviving
and learning and contributing to society
and Building Wealth for their families
but whatever and the guy was like oh
where'd you get that number from so I
give them the statistic and then he just
comes back at me like Oh I thought you
people didn't like the CDC instead of
even acknowledging the number like you
know people just they won't they won't
they won't it doesn't matter what facts
you give them they will not change their
minds because because they're too rooted
in emotion and they refuse to look at
facts and they're just stuck on
emotional decision making that's 14.8
aborted black babies an hour that's
crazy oh my God yeah that's a lot of
little lives it's a lot of little lives
what do you
what are you gonna do that's
what they want I guess
this February we're partnering up with a
Navy SEAL friend of ours Tom Shea hosts
a 21 day virtual event that you guys can
join with us Tom is going to teach you
how to listen to your mind in a new way
and how to control it so that you can
have the discipline you need to build
the life you want so I've seen this
process done for 30 years when you make
it through you will be a different human
being and you'll be able to decide or
make a choice on what really matters so
if you're interested in becoming a
reformed human an absolute animal go to
tomshay.com and use Sunny fast50 for 50
off of this program you will not regret
it you will be a changed person at the
end of it do not miss this
honestly a beautiful moment and one I
have never ever saw before if you have a
heart you know this case is unfair and
you know this loving father deserves to
be reunited look at these girls
children they both deserve to be home
now guys comment your thoughts Down
Below in the comment section please
leave a like subscribe and turn that
notification
this dude is [__] crushing it with
YouTube automation by the way for all
you guys that are looking to make some
money online this dude posts videos
without his face and he's making a whop
off of it right now multiple videos a
day each of these take no time at all
just posting Tate news
free cash
um damn that's it's just [__] man
keeping him there for no reason again
I've said it before and I'll say it
again we don't know all the facts but
the fact is there are not very many
facts so without charges how you can
detain somebody and how the general
public is just just going straight for
the jugular because they don't like
toxic masculinity bring on the toxic
masculinity all of it let's go sick of
this [__] yeah it's prepping on men sick
of it I am sick of it you're crapping on
women too they got men pretending to be
women taking over women's roles in the
world and then you got women telling men
to be less like men like what are we all
supposed to be just some smushy
transgender confused weird homogeneous
creatures it's unnatural it's unnatural
it's not normal and I'm sick I'm just
sick of the conversation I'm sick of it
I'm just gonna eat crickets and uh I saw
a headline and I we have to look into it
but there was this one thing where they
were talking about taking women that
were
um taking like women that were in comas
and making them surrogate mothers like
impregnating them while they were in a
coma and then there was another thing
where there was a doctor talking about
getting living donors for uteruses to
implant into men so like say there was a
woman who wanted to be a man or was
getting a hysterectomy for some reason
and they could take her uterus and put
it in a man I could give you my uterus
and then you could have a baby using
your mommy's uterus wouldn't that be fun
that sounds like the end of times no
that's that's Haram I don't want to hear
it it is Haram it's a bunch of not it's
a bunch of [__] because we don't
want to deal with the real problem which
is mental illness and it's fine it's
fine to be mentally ill it's the same as
being physically ill we gotta deal with
it but cutting off your schlong isn't
the answer indubitably all right thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe join my Discord if you
want a free preview of how I've
generated over five million dollars mom
can vouch if you don't believe me just
look up my name and it legit comes up
that was some crazy [__] that was pretty
lit and um yeah I'll see you right I've
been trying to do that forever
gone
[Music]